hallo Manuel was war deine Meinung nach
der größte Erfolg
was war mein größter Erfolg sagen wir
mal so die meisten Menschen oder bekannt
wurde ich hauptsächlich durch verliebt
Berlin also kann ich natürlich schon
sagen das verliebten Berlin mir sehr
geholfen hat weiterhin meine Karriere zu
gehen aber es gab viele Sachen die sehr
sehr schön waren und die auch vielleicht
weniger Menschen gesehen haben aber für
mich persönlich auch wenn man rein vom
Spiel sehr großer Erfolg hatten kann ich
nicht genau sagen dafür habe ich schon
zu viele verschiedene Sachen gemacht
also ich glaube einfach so das gesamte
ist das was für mich das ganze ausmacht